büsingen ist perfekt aufgestellt für das
digitale zeitalter mit gleich zwei
telefonzellen ich scherrer nicht ich bin
weder bei facebook noch bei twitter sms
ja aber kein whatsapp weil ich habe auch
kein smartphone sondern ein sogenanntes
bauarbeiter handy ich gucke mir das an
auf rbn wie es sind zum teil
fantastische wohnungen aber ich gehe
dann doch ins hotel weil ich einfach
meine ruhe haben will und ich untersteht
auch dann ziel erwartet eine flasche
rotwein und warum und
pippi sind also perfekte gastgeber und
hatten uns auch schon bahntickets an den
kühlschrank geheftet und so das wäre mir
dann alles zu nah würde ich sagen lagen
aber unser wunderbares team ein und
lasst uns das von dem schrecken bitte
gott doch mal jetzt ich teile eigentlich
gerne geld somit der familie so
materielles also irgendwie so den mantel
oder brot auch das glück hatte
fernsehgeschäft